encuentra la factorización en primos de
75 escribe tu respuesta usando una
notación exponencial una anotación
exponencial perfecto primero antes de
hacer la factorización de primos de 75
sería muy bueno recordar que es un
número primo y un número primo es aquel
número que se puede dividir solamente
entre sí mismo y la unidad así que vamos
a escribir aquí una lista de los
primeros números primos un número primo
y bueno ya que estamos escribiendo aquí
los primeros números primos que te
parece si aquí ponemos los números que
no son primos no prima ok un número
primo y un número no primo ahora date
cuenta que el 1 no es primo porque hace
trampa él es la unidad por lo tanto el 1
no es primo el 2 el 2 es un número primo
porque solamente se puede dividir entre
sí mismo y la unidad por lo tanto el 12
es un número primo el 3 el 3 también es
un número primo
es un número primo porque se puede
dividir entre sí mismo y la unidad y
nada más entonces vamos a ponerlo el 4
el 4 no es un número primo porque el 4
se puede dividir entre sí mismo entre la
unidad y también entre 2 por lo tanto el
4 no es primo porque tiene más de 2
divisores el 5 el 5 solamente se puede
dividir entre sí mismo y la unidad y lo
voy a poner aquí en los números primos
el 6 el 6 no es primo porque porque
tiene mitad y tiene tercera entonces
éste no es primo el 7 el siete es un
número que solamente se puede dividir
entre sí mismo y entre la unidad fíjate
que no podemos dividir el 7 entre ningún
otro número
entonces el 7 va a estar aquí el 8 el 8
su número no primo tiene mitad tiene
cuarta y entonces estamos encontrando
más divisores el 9 el 9 podrías pensar
que es primo y tal vez te vayas con la
finta lo puedes poner como un primo pero
ten cuidado
no es primo porque se puede dividir
entre 3 recuerda que el 9 tiene tercera
y por lo tanto no explican ojo un número
primo no es lo mismo que un número impar
hay muchos números impares que no son
primos el 9 el 10 tampoco es primo el 11
el 11 estaría por aquí y así me puedo
mantener sacando primos y primos y
primos y números no primos sino primos
no primos porque son números infinitos
de hecho hay personas que corren
computadoras enormes para encontrar
números primos muy grandes pero
recordemos otra vez el problema
encuentra la factorización en primos de
75 esto quiere decir que a 75 lo voy a
descomponer en primos o dicho de otra
manera voy a escribir al 75 como una
multiplicación de primos y para esto lo
que voy a hacer es un árbol de
factorización voy aquí a poner al 75 y
voy a decir 75 a ti te voy a escribir o
te voy a descomponer en primos
primos tienes bueno pues el 75 no tiene
mitad porque no es número par por lo
tanto no podemos sacarle mitad al 75 75
tendrá 3a
bueno pues recordemos el criterio de
divisibilidad del 3 si yo sumo estos dos
números y es divisible entre 3
entonces 75 es divisible entre 3 haber
75 estos dos es divisible entre 3
por lo tanto 75 también lo es entonces
vamos a sacar la tercera a 75 y la
tercera de 75 cuánto es vamos a hacerle
aquí
75 lo voy a dividir entre 3 y dice 3
cabe dos veces el 73 por 26 y llevamos 1
para 7 bajo el 53 cabe cinco veces en 15
y me sobran 0 por lo tanto cuando yo
factor hizo un 3 en 75 me va a quedar de
este lado 25 o dicho de otra manera al
75 lo podemos ver como 3 por 25 y el 25
el 25 también lo podemos descomponer en
números primos el 20
la tercera pensemos un poco 25 es 7 la
suma es 7 y 7 no es divisible entre 3
por lo tanto 25 no es divisible entre 3
ok no tiene mitad no tiene tercera
pensemos en quinta 25 tiene quinta sí
claro 25 es lo mismo que 5 por 5 de
hecho entonces al 25 lo podemos ver como
5 por 5 y bueno 5 y 5 ya están factor
izados en primos porque tanto el 5 como
el 3 son números primos por lo tanto
estoy diciendo que al 75 lo puedo ver
como 3 por 25 o dicho de otra manera al
75 también lo puedo ver el 75 lo puedo
ver como 3 por 5
5 3 x 5 x 5 media 75 porque 3 por 25
menos 75 esta sería una forma de ver 75
expresado con una facturación de primos
sin embargo nos piden que la respuesta a
la demos usando una notación exponencial
por lo tanto no hemos acabado este
problema para acabar el problema puedo
decir que 75 es igual a quién y bueno
realmente cuando nos piden una anotación
de exponencial lo que nos están diciendo
es que si repetimos un número primo
vamos a ponerlo como exponente es decir
aquí tengo 5 x 5 pero 5 x 5 es lo mismo
que 5 al cuadrado por lo tanto 75 lo
puedo ver como 3 que multiplica a 5
elevado al cuadrado y ya está esta es la
representación de 75 visto como una
factorización de primos el 75 está
descompuesto en números primos cuando lo
tengo igual a 3 por 5 al cuadrado ya
está